I think that I as well as other people
deserve love and so I think maybe I
deserve to be the next Bachelor okay for
real seriously bad boy Chad now trying
to show everyone this whole new tender
side last night but should we buy it
our lauren zima found out when she hit
the gym with the one-man romance
wrecking crew like 190 pounds like it's
not lately
half these dudes in here probably bigger
than me I ate 30 pounds of protein in
three months we're used to seeing Chad
working out or starting fights but last
night a different side I made some
mistakes but um you know I've been
through a lot this last year what was
the point of that yeah you know I think
that you know people saw a bad side of
me people saw me you know being mean
sometimes but yeah I think that everyone
should be capable of being mean when
they have to be lots of talk about who's
gonna be the next Bachelor is that
potentially you it's not gonna be me and
there's no way through maybe I think
it'll probably be Luke I mean he plays
cards right you know he kept everything
on the inside everything I had
spewed out and that spewing out
continues tonight on bachelor in
paradise
in the words of Chris Harrison it is
truly a trainwreck you know a lot is
gonna be revealed on paradise how does
it feel knowing that everything that's
gonna happen is gonna be shown on TV
paradise was just the absolute most
ridiculous you could ever possibly
expected me
everything's uphill from here after
tonight I mean I regret everything that
day but can't take it back so whatever
way goes you have a video message from
actually Jourdan and Jojo oh I'm sure
I'm excited to see this Chad I wish I
had some good advice to give you but I
know that if I said anything you
wouldn't listen anyway so you just keep
doing you I'll do you the point I
wouldn't but not listen I'm not gonna
take advice from Joe dizzle fair enough
a lot of people in our office are
talking about this amazing beer you ever
been considering it I shaved a little
bit for the Bachelorette but then I was
like you know what like I don't like
saving it I like it like this